we are back with the amazing Gabriel
Union and Dr Camila Phillips talking
about all things menopause and rossie is
here in the audience hi hi hi hi hi hi
everybody I love you Rosie I love you
too I got to say I love days like this
I'm learning so much that I had no idea
about and I'm not the only one our
audience members have a bunch of
questions in fact it's a family affair
say hi to John Diane and their son Luke
hi you guys hi I'm great
okay you have a question I was just
wondering uh what advice you would have
for Luke and I on how to deal with
Diane's uh unpredictable and irrational
mood swings and uh how long should we
expect this to last cuz I uh recently
retired and I'm thinking maybe I should
go back to work for a
couple and how do you feel about
it I mean I feel fine I I know that my
behavior is question at times and I
blame everything on menopause but I
think I'm getting through it okay mhm
and can we just ask Luke really quick
how are you
doing well it's hard I mean I love her
but uh sometimes she just acts a little
crazy like I'll be trying to play video
games and my friend mad or we're driving
and she's in the car and just out of
nowhere she'll get mad at me start
yelling at me for some random thing I'll
be like Mom why are you getting mad at
me she'll turn around to my friend Matt
and be like sorry Matt it's menopause
and then I'm like mom why are you
talking to my best friend about
menopause and she's like I don't know
but yeah but I still love her though I
love you
[Music]
guys I mean is it okay to overshare a
little bit no not you're asking me yeah
wrong gu I'm the wrong person maybe we
should ask Gabrielle how does Dwayne
handle it like what do you guys go
through well sometimes he's like is this
a Hollywood thing or a physic phological
thing and I'm like I think it's
Hollywood no um I think part of it is
like being compassionate you know we all
have our Seasons you know we all have
our our times where things get a little
tough for us and it's just about being
like I get it I know you're not crazy I
know you love us and just kind of
keeping that at top of mind um so when
these moments happen you feel supported
and they know that this isn't a any kind
of um indication on how you feel about
them but Dr Phillips how long can this
last I actually really want to know this
answer yeah so symptoms both per
menopause and menopause especially those
mood symptoms can last for a few years
but I have some suggestions for you guys
cuz as a loving family you can get
through this so the first thing is Diane
comes home from work you need to go to
your room you need to De no seriously
you need to go decompressed you don't
need to bother with these two you come
in you need to give her some time to
just decompress from her day and gather
herself one two I think it's really
helpful honestly to have like a code
word code word swordfish that means mom
is having a moment leave me alone figure
out what you're going to do with your
life dinner whatever it is and let her
just have her time because she just
needs to collect herself that is
completely legitim
now I know you're a loving family but
also offload some of her
responsibilities she comes home from
work I'm making an assumption but I
think it's true how about you
know she comes home from a full day of
work to another full-time job you are 17
I am sure at this point you can cook you
can clean you can do laundry take these
responsibilities away from her so that
she can live her best life look at Mom
and then see a doctor for both medical
hormonal non hormonal options so that
you guys can remain loving and bonded
together and funny and laughing funny
and laughing and can we just try it
right now now that we've learned it
swordfish on three 1 2 three swordfish
good that's the code word I'm going to
use it
[Music]
too oh